everybody welcome welcome to december we
are going to get started in just a
little bit a whole bunch of uh familiar
faces and new faces here
all right everyone's zooming by so fast
first up jobs
i know we can't all announce our jobs
here so if you're looking to hire or
you're looking to get hired go to the
job postings channel in the slack the
slack is
nyhackar.slack.com
there's a signup link at myhackr.org
html i'm pretty sure that's where the
link is you can sign up join the meetup
community beyond just uh just the
job postings we have our help python
help get help julia help we have events
posted there we have just general
purpose stuff so it's a it's a nice
community so go to nyhacar.slack.com
but if you need a signup link go to
nmyhackguard.org you can get it from
there
since i am on camera i can take
advantage of that
i'm hiring a data scientist a shiny
developer a linux sysadmin and an
account executive lots of roles if you
want to um work with me and my team go
to landeranalytics.com careers not most
of them are all three of those four are
posted there just apply and um or say hi
to me send me a message on slack or on
twitter or wherever let me know uh
they're always looking for uh
good people to do data science with us
so again if you're
one of the people who's not on camera
you're looking to hire go to job
postings on slack
um
next up pizza
today i got my slice from village square
pizza same place i got last month
because they're so good i just need to
go back there
i only have a little bit of a slice i've
had to share it with my little son so i
had to give him half this slice because
he wanted half of my slice didn't want
his own
it's very good square slices they're
actually known for their
square vodka slices and they're tomato
slices and there's a lawsuit pending
that they stole the recipe from print
street pizza a bunch of employees left
and started their own place and actually
there's another pizzeria on the upper
west side that also is being sued by
print street pizza so we are going to
see how those play out because they
taste almost the same they're really
good
next week we have the
bar in government conference
it says they are in government and
public sector it's much like the new
york r conference except it's really
focused on government and public service
so we have
all sorts of amazing speakers
from across different fields
government-related public sector related
health departments
we have david shore the political
scientist talking we have wendy martinez
from the bureau of labor statistics and
the american statistical association
asam ottumi from pursue care and the big
data bowl
brook frye and ben whit from new york
city council jesuit podcall from
propublica jasmine hahn from bloomberg
we have a talk from colleen zabalos
about submitting to the fda using r
i'm sure max appreciates that with his
uh past and pharma submitting with r is
like holy grail in open source right now
we're really excited about that we also
have workshops
machine learning for the public sector
from john hirsch and climate change data
with alex pagosian
as in the past few years we have an art
auction and max won a piece of the art
auction a few years ago and we have more
art coming up and we have a scholarship
for underrepresented groups which you
can find at
ny you know rstats.ai and i believe we
are posting a link to that
um so if you're a member of an
underrepresented group go there and we
have scholarships available
and
as a member of this meetup group this is
really just a two-day party for our and
friends uh that grew out of this meet up
anyone who wants to attend you can go to
rstats.ai and use code ny hack r for 20
discount because this is meant to be for
the community it is fully online in case
that wasn't obvious we were hoping was
going to be in person much like we hope
the past three conferences we know are
going to be in person but we keep
getting denied by life events
so
um come virtually and hopefully next
year it's gonna be in person where
fingers crossed
um but it's gonna be a really fun time
like you said we have a bunch of great
spears those speakers i named we're just
a few of our speakers we have a whole
bunch more go to rs.ai to see all of
them it's really going to be a good
informative time
over the next few months we have like
the next five meetups planned which is
incredible i love their plans so far in
advance yeah it's shock i see the
shotgun on your face
all right so next month january 20th we
have zj talking about disc dot frame for
those of you that don't know this is a
framework which allows you to
operate on data that lives on files file
or files on disk and use d plier or data
table on them
if you remember ff from back in the day
similar to that and it could even be
considered similar to arrow
we've had an arrow talk recently over
the meet up and the conference i know
there's going to be a talk about dot
frame
then in february on either the 17th or
24th of february we're still working on
the date is hans talking about duckdb
which is a really exciting database
which uses parquet i believe it's part k
as a back end or can use parquet as a
back end has other back ends and allows
you to use through db plier d player
verbs on that so you have a lot of talks
about using extra memory or out of
memory data frames
then in march
fingers crossed this is our return to in
person
hopefully we have david robinson
live coding a shiny app
not going to have slides going to come
here and live maybe last night but he's
going to be live coding a shiny app from
scratch right on screen in front of
everyone
if we are in person we will also be on
zoom we're going to continue doing zoom
in in person and definitely until zoom
goes out of business at which point
we'll find another service
but we'll be on somewhere hopefully in
person it is our goal to be in person in
march but we'll see what letter of the
greek alphabet we're at and decide as we
get closer
then in april we have bill gold talking
about how you can relate the building of
the brooklyn bridge to data science
bill gold has talked to meet up a bunch
of times he always comes up with cool
talks i'm really excited to learn about
the brooklyn bridge in relation to data
science
then in may
we have noam ross who started this all
two years ago in the virtual zooming he
was our first virtual zoom speaker has
very kindly has had
been providing us the zoom link ever
since then on behalf of ecohealth
alliance
he's given talks before about gams he
spoke at the conference about his
package to go from mark down to google
docs and word and back
he's given lots of talks this talk is
going to be not about the pandemic but
about data version control with dalt
so stick to come in may if you want to
learn about that and hopefully the
pandemic will be over and you won't have
to give a talk about the pandemic if
it's raging no i might make you give
another talk about the pandemic we're
going to see what happens
if you have questions for
our illustrious speaker tonight
obviously since you can't ask them on
screen we have two choices either in the
zoom
um chat right here in zoom ask the
question there but please don't because
i can't copy and paste from there better
than that is in the monthly meetup chat
channel of slack so you go to the slack
ny hacker slack that i mentioned before
there is a channel called monthly meetup
chat
if you put in there i can copy and paste
which makes life a lot better at the end
of the meetup
i will collate the questions and ask
max as many questions as we have time
for so we are really looking forward to
all these questions please ask it in
slack if you do it here at zoom i'll get
by it'd be really really awesome if you
did it in slack that'd be great for me
so thank you for that
so
just to recap you're looking for jobs go
to the job postings channel you're
looking for oh yeah folks you should do
this tell me in the chat where you got
your pizza from or your other inferior
food product let me know right in the
chat and let's see what you're eating i
forgot to ask everyone tell me where
you're eating i'd love to see where
everyone's coming from tell me where
you're coming from first of all and
second of all tell me what you're eating
we love to this food is this group is
big on food this big part of this group
is all the eating
so enjoy your food um remember the our
government conference is next week
wednesday thursday and friday
if you want to attend you have a 20
discount code at nyhakar and we have
meetups planned for january february
march april and may which we will
announce and ask your questions in the
monthly meetup chat slack channel or
here in zoom as you're all letting me
know where you're from where you're
eating
so with that i would like to announce
international gummy mule to come give us
a talk um about tidy models one of the
great software products that are it's a
big set of packages and we are really
really excited to have max here's
everyone please golf club for max
hopefully everyone's doing that
let me go ahead share my screen try to
share my screen
yeah we're good
yes we are perfect
all right well thank you of course for
the invitation
uh
and uh
yeah so i thought about uh what to talk
about and uh i thought i'd just go
through you know a lot of stuff that
maybe slipped under radar with tiny
models and then just scope out like the
things will probably well we're working
on now
whether they're sort of like in public
or skunk works
and go through some things that we might
be working on next year um
as sort of like helping us we're
informed by our like user
um
poll or
survey that we do every year so we'll
talk about that a bit these slides are
in the various chats
so yeah let's get going
so maybe you've never heard of tiny
model so what tiny models is it's a
collection of packages
for
different types of modeling like
statistical modeling machine learning
and things like that um basically using
the principles of the tidy verse so in
terms of how we structure code how we
name things how you interact with the
software it's very much based on you
know what we've gotten used to with d
player in in its kin
um if you want to learn more uh i would
suggest going to tidyingmodels.org
or this book that i'll talk about in
just a minute tidy modeling with r
um which i'll show in just a minute
uh if you're getting started you want to
like play around with this in r the
first thing you probably do is install
the tiny moles package it is a meta
package that
installs a variety of both tiny models
and tidy verse packages
um i've got a lot of devel versions here
installed because i'll be talking about
upcoming stuff
um
but you can see it will load things like
broom
d plier ggplot and things like that so
what you would need for basic data
manipulation
and
analysis you would get through loading
this package
the book
i'll open this uh like tinymodels.org is
very good it's got a lot of articles and
a lot of information we've kind of
crafted it to be like a like a a kind of
like home page that you might want to
visit not just some obligatory homepage
if you're learning just if you're new to
tiny models like the get started
articles here are very nice it's a nice
progression through the system
um so that's tinymods.org
uh time modeling with ours here there's
like 21 chapters i think yeah 21
chapters
in the book
and we've been writing it in public
there's like an art for data science
book club or two
so
that's progressing along nicely
all right
so maybe what's new what's been going on
um
one thing we spent a lot of time on
actually i feel like the whole pandemic
we've spent time just on documentation
um so some things that are new in terms
of documentation um we do have a
quarterly quarterly blog post so we tend
to want to post a a make a post on the
teddy bears blog every time we release a
package but sometimes like we release
something that's not all that stupendous
it's just like upkeep and things like
that so uh we have some quarterly blog
posts we're doing there
just to give you you know an overall
like a digest view of what's going on in
the um in the ecosystem
uh the book is nearly complete so that's
why i brought it up
uh we're working with a publisher right
now
um i think we've got like one chapter on
categorical data that needs to be
finished
but the rest of it's there and
great and everything so that'll be nice
once um that will be in print
um another thing that we've been working
on i've spent a lot of time over this
over the last year and i'm still working
on it is uh if you've never heard of
parsnip it's sort of the part of tidy
models that gives you sort of like the
common interface to a bunch of different
r packages
so you know you don't have to memorize
all the differences between what lm does
and glimnic does and stan does and so on
and so on
so parsnip's goal is to give you sort of
like an overall
one api
for a bunch of modeling functions and
the way it's structured is
you kind of like pick a model that you
want to use like linear regression or
nearest neighbors model or a random
forest and then once you
choose what kind of model you want like
the structure of the model then what you
do then is choose what we call the
engine and the engine is basically how
am i going to fit this model so if i
start with a linear regression model let
me show you some code so i'll load
parsnip
if you wanted to fit let's say let's say
decision tree
um
you would
start with a decision tree function and
let's say you want to fit like a c5o
tree so you could do set
engine
and the engine here tells you how you
want to fit the model so if you want to
use c50 you can do that if you want to
use our part you can do that or you know
spark i think
there's a variety of different ways to
fit that particular model so that so the
way you do the specification is you
choose the model type like decision tree
you choose the methodology you want to
use like spark or our part
and so on and then the third thing you
might have to do sometimes is set the
mode so in a model like a decision tree
it could be either like classification
or regression
and so in those cases you would set them
up so it's like a like a three level
specification of models
um
and uh and that's how you you
you use them
so the first thing we did is for
documentation
is we have some of these models have a
lot of different engines you can use
like the as you'll see in a minute the
linear regression engine has or model
has quite a number of engines and we
want to put as much as we can in the
documentation for those so that's really
helpful so you know there's a lot of
peculiarities around glimnet about how
it works and things like that so we want
to give users this information
but at the same time then we have like
an engine like stan
it's pretty straightforward but has a
lot of potential options you might want
to use like the number of cores
or the priors and so on so what we
wanted to do is we want to have a lot of
this documentation in one place but we
found that when we just put it in the
help file for like linear reg it got to
be like super long and then nobody reads
it because it's kind of a bear to get
through
so one thing we started to do in the
last uh published version
of parsnip is when you go to
like a page help page for something like
clear
what you get is you get this like linked
list of engines
so for linear regression based on the
package that i've loaded which is
parsnip
you could fit a linear regression model
using lm
glimnet stand spark or kiris
and then if you go to any one of these
like if you go the stan one
what you see is it tells you about um
you know what you can do in this
particular case of linear aggression so
you can only fit a regression model
there's no real tuning parameters to
speak of for this model but then there's
some things that you might want to know
about because you might forget what the
options are so you know we document
things like what are the options you
might want to set for this particular
model and tell tell you about them and
also give you links to find out more
and so on in some cases
um i don't think we really have it here
but like for glemnet for example we have
details on pre-processing that tell you
things like yeah you should center in
scale for this
uh and so on and then we also have a
link to
a whole page of examples
uh at the um the pakistan site and so
the cool thing about this is
if you've just loaded
parsnip you have these engines available
to you
but we also have a lot of like what we
call parsnip extension packages that are
specific to certain types of models so
if you're into like rule based models
there's like a patch called rules or if
you want to do a variety of different
like poisson regression models there's a
package called poisson rag and what
happens is
some of these add new engines to a
particular model function and so
whenever i go to one of these help pages
right now it's dynamic so it looks and
sees what i have installed right now or
what i have loaded in my r session and
it adjusts this list accordingly based
on what you have available so for
example there's a development package we
have called multi-level
multi-level mod
and once i load that and go back to
linear regression you'll see that
there's more engines down here
so you see now we have like a lemur
uh ge lme and so on
um
so it's dynamic in that like we our
first inclination is and not not show
you a bunch of engines that you don't
have installed that you can't use
um it looks at what we have loaded at
any particular time
um and this has worked pretty well um
there's some sort of back end things
that we want to change about this
um
and so um
so we might in the next version of
parsnip justice a little bit
one of the reasons we might adjust this
list a little bit is because we have a
new mode so right now we have is i'll
talk about this in more detail in a
minute but we have like classification
regression models we're adding a new
mode that sensor progression so if
you're doing like survival analysis or
any time to event modeling
that really they're numbers but you have
to account for censoring and things like
that so instead of like
hijacking the regression mode
we have very specific things you can do
for those models so we have a new mode
and so what we might want to do and i
haven't really decided exactly how to do
this yet
is you know glimnet you might have mode
you might have engines for like
like two of the three modes or something
like this and so we want to be able to
have something here that indicates which
models you can use for regression or
sensor regression or classification so
there might be some more that we'll be
doing with this but it's a nice little
feature
that like a like an example of a glimnet
is it has a lot of detail about the
model and things like that but there's a
lot of a lot of things that we get
questions about just because this model
which is wonderful model um is a little
bit different so we have things like
glibnet details like if you want to know
how to
set the regularization path or
a few other sort of like pro tips
um using this type of documentation
really allows us to um
flesh things out without getting in the
way
of um users when they're looking for
documentation so that's kind of nice
um
yeah uh and i was gonna say more about
parsnip but uh i was reminded seeing
gnome in the
in the chat a minute ago
that one thing i don't have on here
is we added in the list here is we added
a generalized
additive model function so if you want
to fit that you can do that through tiny
models which is nice
and we also added in the development
version of bart
model so if you want to fit bayesian
adaptive regression trees
we have some engines for that so those
are two new models that we put in
that i didn't think about when i was
doing slides
something else that came up actually
david robinson had this thought and put
in some um some issues for us and one of
his ideas was you know these these
models should have like a default engine
so you know when we look at like linear
regression i think the go-to for most
people is to just use lm
and so when originally when we
envisioned parsnip having multiple ways
to fit the model we didn't really have
any default and so what we did was um we
added defaults to each of the the models
that we have so for
so if you look at the arguments for the
regression the engine
is defaulted to lm
for decision trees it's defaulted to our
parts and this you know the
documentation
in fact if you look back the help file
you may have noticed
that it says default here
so that's nice and the nice thing about
that is if you're just fitting like the
standard lm model you don't have to do
this separate set engine bit
so it really makes the code a lot more
simple so that was a nice suggestion
from david that we thought was a great
idea
something else that we did across sort
of all our packages
is
you know we we build these models and
preprocessors and things like that and
you know people want to get the
underlying details out of it so if you
run like a fit with a parsnip
function you get like a parsnip object
back that has like the lm object sort of
embedded into it there's a lot of good
reasons you might want to get that you
might want to do plots with it
or
you know whatever you want to with it
and so originally we had like a variety
of different functions like pool model
fit and things like that um or
pool workflow
the problem with those is they weren't
really well designed and that's that's
my fault um they weren't generic so the
pool model fit you can only work run on
a like a parsnip object
um if you had a workflow and you wanted
to pull the model fit then that was a
little bit weird and awkward so what we
did is we spent some time coming up with
like a comprehensive set of extract
functions and these functions are named
better
uh they're more organized
and they generally work better so for
example
it doesn't matter whether you have a
parsnip object a workflow a workflow set
we have methods that will extract out
the actual underlying fit object so that
we call that the engine fit
so extract fit engine will pull out the
lm model
from um from linear
like an object produced by linear reg
if you have a workflow and you want to
get the the parsnip model you can get
that out
and so all these things work across all
the different types of objects that we
have
so this is a nice little
api that we we use all the time as
developers
but uh it's a lot more it's a lot
cleaner than what we were doing before
and so we took a lot of time to um to
put all these together and it affected
like every package that we had so it was
a fair amount of work but we're pretty
happy with how it ended up
there's been a variety of different
recipe updates
um these are so what recipes is it's a
package that you can use to do
pre-processing
for your data before putting it into a
model or visualization
so for example you think about like
model.matrix and base r is really nice
it'll create dummy variables for you you
can log data and so on and so forth
recipes is kind of like monodot matrix
sort of like mashed together with d
plier where you come up with a
sequential piped in set of steps to your
recipe
that you might do things like
uh create dummy variables or
collapse factors based on their
frequency in the data you might use it
to do principal component analysis or
you might do it use a recipe to um
like re-encode a factor and things like
that so it's really geared towards
modeling and visualization and it's very
um and we have like i think we're up to
like 120 recipe steps so there are a
whole variety of things you can do to
make new features
like if holidays are important to your
data like if you have a time-based
analysis there's like a step that'll
create indicators for christmas and
various holidays and things like that
it's very very versatile and it works
really well
um so some of the updates we've done the
recipes
is the first one is we have a lot of
requests when you do
like a like a feature extraction method
to retain the original predictors so
imagine that you have like a data set
with like 10 really
um
highly correlated predictors like
there's this data called the beans data
set that's on cran that has a bunch of
features in the data so a lot of a lot
of data points and like about 10
features
and these features are highly highly
correlated and a lot of models might be
harmed by that correlation so one thing
you might do is you might convert the
original predictors to a set of
principal components which are
uncorrelated but but still carry along
the majority of the information that was
in the original data set
so that's really nice the thing is
originally if you use step pca on that
then it would get rid of those 10
predictors automatically and just
replace them with the principal
components and then we have a lot of
recipe steps that do similar things like
that and so then the question we had
through github issues was well yeah i
don't want to lose the originals i kind
of want to keep them in there
and so in all the
the recipe steps that we have that do
anything like pca where you would be
computing one or more features from one
or more
of the original columns there's an
option called um
uh you'll see in a minute called keep
keep original calls that you can set in
these recipe steps so that you can keep
the originals in there which is nice
so maybe that's
so yeah i'll get to that minute
another thing that we figured out is we
had a lot of github and stack overflow
questions where people had like an
outcome
variable that was a factor so they're
going to do classification
and most our models want those
classification outcomes to be factors
not like integers or
binary
columns they just want to keep a factor
as a factor
and what we were noticing noticing is
people were making dummy variables and
selecting using all nominal and nominal
here means uh categorical like being a
factor or a character uh column so in
recipes you can use d plier selectors we
also have a set of very specific uh
types of selectors that either are based
off of the role of the data like whether
it's a predictor or an outcome or also
the data types you might use like all
numeric here if you wanted to
uh the problem that we were seeing was
people were doing step dummy and then
using all nominal which would also
capture the outcome here and so then
when they go to do their modeling and
they say like class tilde something
that class column wasn't there anymore
because it got converted to dummy
variables and was named differently
so um
so we came up with more specific
selectors so for example if you want to
do
just numeric predictors we have
selectors that usually uh select on both
the type of data
and the role in the analysis
and we change almost all of our training
materials over to these
um just so it gets emphasized um the
original selectors don't go anywhere
they're still there but i think these
are the ones that people want 99.9
percent of the time
um it's going to get rid of a lot of um
accidental bugs
in the recipe
um so that's two new changes of recipes
and then we have a smattering of like
new um steps like there's one that does
like harmonic features for time series
analysis
um one that i started working on during
a sliced competition
uh
episode where you were getting a column
of um
of data that were like things you would
make indicators for like imagine if you
had a column for what languages somebody
spoke but it was multiple choice because
you know people speak multiple languages
and so you wanted to make dummy
variables from those but there are
multiple choice as opposed to like a
regular factor where it's just like one
of the categories so text recipes um
emil finished that um
that work i started to make a multiple
choice dummy variable step
which is nice
we also in the embed package which also
has recipe steps
we made some new um
sort of sparse pca steps
so for example if you wanted to
let the pca estimation potentially get
rid of predictors that are not that
um important
um you could do that so we have two ways
of doing it there's two steps in
in embed that do that one's based on
variational based methods and the other
is more of a traditional sort of
regularized like limnet lasso type of
penalty so that's nice
so you know you may have started off
with like just basic step pca
with all
predictors now we can let you do that
with all numeric predictors because
that's what you would want probably for
pca
and then if you want to keep the
original columns you can you can do that
and then maybe instead of using instead
of using step pca you can use
step pca
sparse bays
so the two new ones are called step pca
sparks instead pc is sparse bays because
they're different estimation methods
so that's
so that's what kind of we've been
working on for like the last i don't
know like six months or so
um
we've done a fairly you know
comprehensive job on a bunch of packages
this will give you a sense of what we're
working on now which is probably going
to generate the most maybe discussion
um
so first thing which is sort of like
i'll just be honest with you it's been
like the bane of my existence is case
weights so case weights is a situation
where
you know let's take like uh empty cars
right there's like 32
rows in that data set
um
case weights would be an extra column in
the dataset that's not a predictor or an
outcome
it's like almost like um
uh there's different types of case
weights you could have so for example
let's say you had like a subset of the
that data set
that had the same number of cylinders
and the same like engine displacement
and weight
um they have the same like covariate
patterns like data patterns um
you can imagine if you had like
categorical predictors and a categorical
outcome you might have a lot of
different data points that fit that same
pattern and so instead of giving them
individual rows in the data set what you
can do is just have the pattern
represented once and have another
column that says how many times it
occurred right so we call that frequency
weighting where basically a lot of times
it's a good thing when you want to
compress
large data
into a
data frame if you have very like
discrete data
or very granular data you might do like
basically like a account a d player
account and get all the patterns and
then get there the number of times they
occur
and so they're not all modeling
functions but many of the modeling
functions allow you to use case weights
in the analysis so whether you have that
expanded set of all the rows or like
just the unique patterns with their
weights you would get the same results
from those two different data sets
um so frequency weighting is one thing
you might do there's like three or four
different standard weighting
methods or waiting situations
another one is called importance
weighting and i've used this quite a bit
in my analyses like if you have data
that is over time let's say you have
data that goes across you know 10 or 15
years you might want your model to to
use all that data but really emphasize
the most recent data because that's the
most relevant but you don't want to just
like kick data out so what you can do is
you can use what's called an importance
weight where you relatively weight each
data point
let's say the weights were between zero
and one you might have the most recent
data have weights around one and the
oldest data have weights around like 0.1
or something like that
and a weight of zero would mean it
doesn't get used at all
so
importance weighting is a separate uh
method you can use it's not really
related to frequency weighting but
mathematically all the computations are
kind of the same in terms of the model
right so we have a bunch of different
ways that people might use case weights
and although i've thought about this a
lot in my career anything about hard
enough
so you know carrot you can use case
weights
but
in mlr3 and things like that you can use
kate's weights but i don't know that any
of us really thought about wait how do i
resample data so if i have
like frequency weighting
and i do 10-fold cross-validation
do i just do it on the rows do all the
patterns go into the test set or
do all them go in the training set or
should i split them does that make sense
like you know there's no real obvious
answer to that question but we do need
to have the ability in our sample to
make splits of the data whether it's in
a training set or a test set or through
like bootstrapping or cross-validation
to make sure we have the ability to take
those weights into account when we do
our data splitting
so this is going to be a situation where
we're going to do like a lot of
documentation that say yeah for our
sample you know important weights i
don't think should be used
in the resampling or data splitting
tools but if you do want to split
using the frequency weights then we need
to give people an interface to make that
split
which is not trivial necessarily so
that's something we never thought about
excuse me another thing that we need to
consider is
you know a lot of our work and tidy
models relies on empirical validation
where you can fit models but we really
quantify them by how well they fit the
data and so
with all these different types of case
weights there are some situations like
frequency weighting when you want those
case weights to be used when you measure
let's say accuracy or the airing of the
curve
right you don't want to like if there's
a particular pattern you're really bad
at missing if you ignore the case
weights you'll probably get very
optimistic estimates of performance
because you're not giving that the
appropriate weight
right so for um for frequency weighting
it makes a lot of sense to include the
case weights
in measuring performance but then again
with something like importance weighting
you most likely don't want the caseways
to impact performance
so it's a really interesting situation
is we're going to be enabling these for
all stops of the modeling process but we
have to do a lot of education say like
hey we never really thought about this
too much before but now we're thinking
about it and you have some options based
on whatever problem that you're working
on
one other aspect of this is
uh recipe steps so you know we have like
over 100 recipe steps
some of them most of them make sense to
think about case weights so if you're
doing like centering and scaling and you
have case weights you want to make sure
your means and standard deviations
use the weighted mean and weighted
weighted standard deviation to normalize
the data like you wouldn't want to
ignore the weights when you're doing
that
the problem is r doesn't have case
weights
um distributed across all of its
statistical functions and a really good
example that is principal component
analysis that the standard pr com
function in r that we use all the time
doesn't enable case waves so it'll be a
weird situation where we
center and scale using our case weights
but we don't apply those same weights
when we do pca that would be like a
little bit of a disconnect
and so there's when we can solve that
easily we will but there's going to be a
problem
um when people go to use case weights is
that some of the recipe steps
you can do case weights with but others
you can't and some of those are because
it's just impossible in other situations
it's going to be because it's not been
implemented and i actually i was talking
to brian lewis who i think many of us
from the audience know
about you know doing weighted pca and he
was talking about like well it'll have
to do that and you know like i say that
all the time too and it doesn't
necessarily happen and then just this
morning i figured out like a really
simple base r way to get
weights into principal component
analysis
so we're just sort of like irritably
trying to solve each one of these
situations and it's just taking forever
just to be honest with you like there's
a really sort of angry github
um
issue about this where people are asking
like why does it take so long and we
have to say like oh well we have to take
all our performance measures and make
them use case weights and in some cases
we there's no formula in the literature
for that so we have to sort of figure it
out as we go
so it's something that we need to do
it affects all of our packages it's not
really sexy but the work's getting done
it's in process but it's still going to
be
a bit of time before we have this
completely enabled across tiny models
but it is a big investment of our time
another thing that we're really excited
about is sensor regression
so if you've never heard of censoring
it's basically when you have numeric
data especially time to event data
and you know
partially what the value should be so
let's say we're talking about data in
adoptions like in a shelter
so let's say we have a dog come in 10
days ago we know
how long it's been at the shelter but it
hasn't been adopted yet so we don't know
it's time to adoption but we know it's
at least let's say 10 days
so what you don't want to do is you
don't want to bias your data analysis by
saying oh well we don't know the answer
to that yet so we shouldn't include that
particular dog in the data analysis that
biases the results so typically what
people do is in the data set they give
that in that situation which is called
right centering they would give that
dog's value 10 but have like an
indicator next to it that says oh we
don't know exactly what the final value
is that's called centering okay
r is really strong in survival analysis
there's dozens of packages
uh that do this
a particular type of analysis some of
them are for like you know mostly
medical applications um and so on but
there's other applications you can use
for time to event data
um
the problem is is that the quality of
packages
is uneven uh on on a good day it's
uneven
you have some that are really well
documented
some that are not really documented at
all and you have to look through a bunch
of code to figure out exactly what
they're doing
the interfaces are all different so um
so that's a problem uh and another thing
is
we have some core packages in r
that uh for survival analysis and for
sense or sensor regression that are very
very functional and they've been around
for a while but if you start to program
against them as a developer
uh you're kind of
not going to go very far they're not
really written to be extensible i feel
like they were written for the the
people who the maintainers for their own
personal
like applications and usage
um and they're not necessarily
interested in extending it so people can
call certain sub functions and so on
from their package so you know we've had
to re-implement a ton of stuff for
survival analysis
because the original
tools are not really user friendly or
developer friendly
um so that's not been a great time but
we're getting through it and it also
allows us to make you know some some
choices that we think maybe the original
functions didn't do particularly the way
we would like it to and and really like
these three points here this is
basically why carrot exists why tidy
models exist and so on um that we want
to make this a better user experience
for people
um who would be consumers of these
analyses
so that's nice
we can do that
um when you load the
censored package so it's not a crayon
yet you can install it using remotes
it automatically loads a survival
package
we use the same uh formula interface as
a survival pack because that works
pretty well
so for example
if you're doing an analysis where the
the times are in a variable called time
the sensoring indicator is called status
the common thing to do is use this
function called serve which sort of
melds those two pieces of information
together into one and then you can give
it your basic modeling function
there's some special functions inside
survival to do like stratification and
so on so you know we have decided to
sort of standard on the survival
packages formula method
and
utilize that
so when you load the sensors package you
get access to like the proportional
hazards model and let's say we're
fitting like a regularized
uh cox model
using glimbet so you can say what
penalty you want
you have to tell it to use a glimnet
engine and then you can give it
the formula that you want to use
in this particular case we're going to
use the long data without the first
three rows and then we can get our
standard
model fit for glimnet now not to pick on
glimmer too much but it's a good example
of why we need something like censored
is
this this formula interface has been
around i think some of the survival
documents from the like the late 80s
it's it's
and it was originally like an s thing
that got translated over to r
it's been around for quite a while it's
i think a fairly standard thing
so if you want to fit a cox model with
strata so that they have different um
baseline hazards for in this case for
sex
um this formula
you've been able to do that for i don't
know like 40 years
uh
30 years
but some of the the people who implement
packages don't necessarily think about
that so um so for example glimnet when
you want to set
what the stratification variable i mean
it's not exactly a predictor but it kind
of is
and glimnet doesn't use the serv
standard serve function uh
method it makes you
create a separate sort of serve like
object
that for the outcomes that has the
stratification is bundled with the
outcome data and that's really kind of
weird to me that
it's to me it's sort of confusing the
dependent and independent variables
gloominet doesn't use the formula method
so maybe that's why they did what they
did but it's really not intuitive and
it's really different than the sort of
the standard interface and so one of the
great things about tiny models is we
tend to fix that so if you go to fit the
glimnet engine you use the regular
strata formulation and then we translate
this back to what glimnet wants and
allow you to fit the model the way
uh you know r has intended to do it for
decades
so we sort of fix these things on the
back end or make them consistent on the
back end
another thing we do is
which i really appreciate having used a
lot of survival models in the past is a
lot of times for some packages when you
get the want to get the probability of
survival up to a certain time
you can get those in the prediction
method but they only give it to you at
the time
that your event was
so if you have like event times that
range from like
like zero to 100 you could only get the
survival probability prediction at your
particular event time as opposed to
having them all be the specific event
time like if you want to make a plot of
the data or make predictions for example
the data so for example we've
implemented a type equal survival method
and then you give it what times you want
the computations done at it doesn't
matter what time your individual outcome
was
listed at we give you all the
predictions we give them to you in a
nested tibial
so one of the things we do in tiny
models is that
uh we always the predictions always have
the same number of rows as what you
started with so if my data i'm
predicting has three rows the output of
the predict method will always have
three rows but again we're getting
predictions at a thousand time points
here so what we do is we make a nested
table here which looks intimidating but
the standard unness function will then
just like collapse this into a really
long format so it's pretty simple to use
in practice
so for example
uh what you could do is i have three
things i predicted that are in this
nested tibble i could just give them
like sample labels that go from a b and
c
once i unnest this
i don't have three rows anymore i have
3000 rows that have a very specific and
repeatable naming structure
it's a data frame which is nice a lot of
the survival packages based on matrices
and then you can just use you know
standard ggplot to get a really nice um
survival curve predicted survival curve
for three particular data points
so you know it's a little bit of tidy r
in here
but it's it's really nice compared to to
be honest with you what the other
modeling
methods give you um there's less hoops
to jump through
the outputs are very very standardized
and so i think it makes it a lot easier
to work with it
uh this probably needs to be updated i
know hannah so hannah frick has been
working on this
um
i think she added some more things in pr
today so you know we have like the
standard like um
uh
proportional hazards models the
parametric hazard models
um with different engines you know
different ways to fit those models we
have a few decision trees boosting
bagging random forest
um we hannah wrote a blog post about
this for the tiny model or the teddy
works blog which we link to this um
this link here
so on our studio community we have like
a post about this we want to hear what
people want to do
um censoring
in survival house is a really really
rich field we want to make sure we're
meeting anybody's needs so if this is
something you're interested in maybe
look at the sensor package and then come
out and comment on this r studio
community thread about the things that
you think would be really helpful
like this person listed quite a lot of
things
i've never done much with state
multi-state models for survival analysis
but that seems to be something people
want and so they're talking about that
and telling us like oh here the packages
that people tend to use and so on so
this is your chance to give us any
feedback on
you know either what we've already done
or that things that you might want the
sensor package to do
so that's very very helpful
for us as developers to know what's
important
so that's censored it's not on cran yet
um hopefully it will be it won't be by
the end of the year because the end of
the year is rapidly approaching but i
don't think it's going to be
uh in development the first version for
like an extended period of time
maybe january february we'll put this on
cram
now the thing that people
really have been really really really
interested in is model operations
so before i joined our studio i was
working at pfizer i did a lot of
different stuff there in drug discovery
but one thing i did work on in the first
few years there was with computational
chemistry models
and so what you do in computational
chemistry is you take anything a
medicinal chemist might want to know
about a molecule like a potential drug
candidate and then you find ways to
measure that like using like lab tests
and assays and things like that and then
we would build models for everything
that we could so for example there are a
bunch of different lab tests you could
use to predict different types of
toxicity like
like you know liver toxicity or
you know oncology you know metagenetic
or oncology
based toxicities and things like that so
one thing i did and help people do also
at pfizer was to build models to make
predictions that our medicinal chemists
could like on their computer design a
new drug and then get a quick look at
like what the prediction is for its you
know toxicity or its effectiveness and
so on and so in pfizer what we did is we
built this really ground up
java based
method for
monitoring
and versioning models because we were we
had dozens and dozens of models and so
this is model operations is that process
where you take a model hopefully you
document it but you publish it so an api
is available to other people you might
update that model later on so you want
to version the model and the predictions
you might want to monitor the model to
see how it does over time and so on and
all those that host of things you do
when models get put into production is
what we call model operations and it's
something that i don't think ours really
had
in any real way for quite a long time
at least nothing based through r so
there's things like ml flow
and some other tools that were built for
languages other than r which you can
sort of shim r into but the more we use
them it was just kind of
just a disaster to be honest with you
like for ml flow for example you could
only install r through python
and and so like just getting our working
uh was really really difficult um
so it wasn't really built for r
and um
and really hard to make like um for me
it seems really hard to make ml flow
multilingual so one thing that julie's
been working on like since she started
really julia silke
is to talk to a lot of customers about
what they want for model operations how
they're doing it now if they're doing it
all
and really get a set of
requirements for what people might be
interested in and so that's finally came
to fruition recently we haven't really
talked about this too much not for any
particular reason but um i'm talking
about tonight with julie's permission uh
is there a package called vetiver
which is on crayon right now we did the
initial crayon release if anybody's ever
submitted a package frame you'll
understand why we did this is we put
basically like the minimum functionality
into the package and then send it to
crayon
so the created version right now doesn't
have a you can use it and things like
that but it doesn't have all the bells
and whistles that the development
version does which you can download and
use whenever you want to it's just when
you send something to crayon the more
functions you have the more likely
they're going to get really persnickety
about something
so um so that's sort of like sometimes
the
the strategy that we use
um so what better whatever can do right
now is you can publish version and
deploy models using the pins package
so pins is a package we've had for a
while that had the reworked recently
that's basically like an api to like
blob storage whether you want to use
like a local
basically structure for your data or s3
or studio connect or what have you or
azure or something like that with pins
what you do is you can take our objects
and basically pin them to like a storage
cloud and you can version them and
things like that so it's a really
natural way
to think about um
taking models and putting them somewhere
that other people can get to that and
reference them
and then plumber you've probably heard
of which is a really nice uh r package
for uh making apis through r so
basically you can get like a like a web
api which i'll show you in just a second
um that's an interface to any r code and
what vitover does is it combines pins
and plumber to basically let you take
any particular model whether it's like
an individual like lm model or an
individual xg boost model
or it could be a model from tiny models
like through parsnip or workflows or a
carrot model or a mlr3 model and when
you take those objects you run them
through
the functions that are in vetiver that
i'll show you in a minute and basically
it's a way to automatically like put it
somewhere that it can be used for
deployment and then give you like a
programming interface to that api so you
can get predictions from it whenever you
want so it's really really elegant i
think i think the api is really nice
and um
and we'll be doing a lot more of that
as you see over time
so here's how it works
is you load better so the word vetiver
is actually um julie can do a better job
of telling you about this it's basically
like an oil that's like a stabilizing
agent
uh in perfumes
so it's something that sort of binds
everything together and that seemed kind
of like an apropos name for this package
um
so let's say we take uh i don't know the
sacramento housing data
we built a random forest model on it
using this formula
we put it in a model workflow using tidy
models but this could be carrot or mlr3
whatever you want to use and then all
you do is say
you know take this model fit and make it
into a vetiver model and give it
basically the tag of in this case
sacramento
under bar rf
and then what it does is there's a
couple things it does like it butchers
the works flow which means what butcher
does is it gets rid of a bunch of extra
stuff in that random forest object that
you don't need for prediction so
sometimes like these model objects
especially for large data sets have
things like the fitted values and the
residuals for the original training set
you don't need those if you're making
predictions so the butcher package that
we have
can take all that stuff out and still
let you use your model for prediction
so that's an option here that's
defaulted to on
so it takes that butchered workflow
uh pins it i'm sorry it converts it to
um what pins will use
um
to to store it and so at that point
you've just converted the model to what
we have is a vetiver model
so then once you have that
um you can create a model board if you
don't have one which is basically where
you store your models
your model board might be in connect or
azure or s3 wherever you want to keep it
and then all you do is you pin the model
to your board so it's there it gets
versioned right so it has a date and
then basically like a hash after it
and then from there you can reference it
any way you want to
so in plumber you can use the pr
function
uh that will basically give it um
an api
on a website so the the code is very
simple if you use plumber before you
have the pr function which does not
stand for pull request
and then you use the vetiver pr predict
and it sets up a prediction interface on
whatever port you want
and so and then it's available as an api
which is pretty nice
and then what i'm going to do is uh
hopefully i should have like refreshed
it a minute ago it might take a minute
to get
uh
up and going again
let me refresh here's one that uh based
on a model that julia made
and this model takes basically uh
character string
and she built a model based on some
netflix data
that would um
that would classify based on a
description of
the media to predict whether it was a tv
show
or oh there it is whether it was a tv
show or a movie right so if i can type
in whatever i want to hear it'll give me
a model prediction back
so some nice things about it is
if you look at the predict api so this
is a plumber api page
um
it gives you a nice description of what
the inputs to the model are and in this
particular model it's just a text string
that says description and it tells you
what type it is but if you were looking
at that random force model i built a
little bit ago that had like bedrooms
bathrooms and square footage this array
here would be
list those variables and their types and
so that you can see what should be
coming in and then as you'll see in a
minute when i run this you'll get you'll
see the json that comes out of it that
gives you predictions
um so again this is uh showing you how
the api works you would you know would
use this this um this api
programmatically to get predictions as
fast or as many as you want
so let's take this little example tab
i can type in whatever i want to
[Music]
so in the chat
tell me
what movie you think this is
a dude in his rock collection saw world
hunger
i'll give you a minute or two to think
about what that is
um
but if i put this in here
then basically i can do i think it's try
button
and i get a prediction back that this is
a movie which is true
so this is the uh my really really bad
description
of uh avengers infinity war where you
know thanos uh uses rock collection
assault world hunger
uh even worse than that is let's do this
one
medieval people combat climate change
with swords
uh
that's from the much maligned uh game of
thrones
and so again if i hit you know try hero
give me prediction
uh which looks like it is
also movie
so just just shows you how it works
uh it's a very nice interface if you've
ever used plumber it's super super easy
to use
and i think you can tell from the code
that we have here it's a pretty
pretty simple process to take your model
convert it to a vetiver model
pin it to the board that you want and
then you can deploy it as an api using
like you know basically three lines of
plumber code which is nice
um i'll go through the
questions at the end
um
so that's something that you can use
today
uh we'll be adding a lot more to it if
you're gonna try it definitely try
loading the um the devel version because
that's where all the features are right
now and then we'll submit that version
of crayon pretty soon i think
so we'll be doing more and more and more
model deployment
for example julia
has a pr that's in the work to come up
with a template for model cards so model
cards are um
a way to
document your models like here's the
intended use of this model here's the
population you should be predicting
using this model
here's the data that went into it here's
the description model and so on so it's
like a really uh there's a nice paper
about here are the things that you care
about
uh that you should document for any
model that you're deploying so anybody
uses it you can understand what the
limitations of it like the data was
built on and that sort of thing so we're
automating some ways to um
to get model cards uh at least uh the
template to write it out because it's
honestly it's a bunch of like user
written data there's some of that we can
derive from the objects and things like
that but again like when i was back in
pfizer every
model had to have a have documentation
so a medicinal chemist could look and
say oh i should use this model to
predict how much of the drug gets into
the bread blood brain barrier passes
that barrier and if we had models that a
neuroscientist wanted those are mostly
built on things that get through to the
brain because that's what
neuroscientists want to do but if any
other project that didn't want a drug to
get into the brain
probably shouldn't use that model
because it wasn't really built for the
types of compounds that they were
looking at so these model cards are
really good ways to document the
intended use of your model and discuss
its limitations and what it's good at so
that's a pr that we have um
uh
in process that you know if you want to
give us feedback that would be really
helpful
and then finally
um
we do
i don't think it's every year but i
think it's like about a year and a half
so far we do like a user survey where we
um give them a link
we ask them like one or two questions
about themselves and then we give them a
list of features that we're thinking
about working on and then we give them
like a hypothetical hundred dollars and
they can say oh i put like fifty dollars
on this feature but i don't really care
about that one but i'll give it like
five bucks and so it's a good like
survey method that we use to get
a sense of what's really important to
users it's not like a contract so it's
not like if something gets ranked the
highest we're guaranteed to do it but
most of these things are on our
development list anyway so it gives us a
a way to help prioritize work
so
we just did the the analysis of the
survey
you can see just like the first time we
did it
most of the responses come in the first
few days and then they're sort of like a
constant trickle over like a month or
two
so we're looking at about almost 600
responses so far
this was a nice change from last year uh
the bar of i've never used tidy models
was maybe like you know a third of the
way higher than it was um this year so
more people who are responding or using
tidy models they're mostly people that
have used the packages once or a lot of
times and there were like 50 people
i didn't vote um but 50 people that have
either contributed or taught with it
uh or so on who would be considered
people that like have the most
experience so you know the majority of
the people here are consumers of these
the software so that was that was nice
to see
uh they tend to work in industry
um there's a you know
another population of people who are in
academia or researchers
students and then hobbyists or a smaller
percentage so most people here 61
uh work in industry of some type
and then here's sort of the results
there's when we publish the the blog
post about this we'll have more detail
but this is pretty solid ranking
across different ways we cut it
is much to my chagrin
uh supervised feature selection seems to
be the thing that people want the most
so this would be something like
recursive feature elimination
or like supervised filters that maybe go
into recipes
um i'll be honest you know i wrote an
old book about this and i don't think
it's a great tool like it's good and it
works but they're computationally very
very expensive so they're often not
worth the the time it takes to to run
them but
but we you know i've done it once with
carrot and honestly when when i started
to write that other book on feature
selection i got like halfway through a
bunch of tiny models code and kind of
stopped for a while so i think some of
this is just laying around needs to be
reworked
but that was the most important thing
that people wanted probably above the
noise here is also model fairness
analysis and metrics which is something
that
seems pretty obvious um it's you know
it's a good idea so this there's a bunch
of different ways you can do this you
can do analysis of your let's say your
training sets
uh before it goes into a model and say
like which groups are underrepresented
and so on
there's a bunch of ways to measure
um just
or inappropriate impact on on
particular groups so you know like the
the classic example is if you're doing
like
predicting loan defaults you know some
some marginalized groups have high false
positive rates meaning that the model
tends to predict that they default more
than they actually do
and that's not i don't think any
nefarious choice on anybody's part it's
mostly based on what data is coming into
the model and how models utilize that
data so i think there's a lot we can do
pre-modeling and post modeling
both as both like a performance metric
and also a sort of a post-hoc
descriptive analysis of how well your
model is working with respect to
individual
individuals or groups of individuals
so that's something that seems like an
obvious thing to do there's a couple of
our packages that do a little bit of
this but it's not very comprehensive
um
the other things seem to be following
like a little bit of a uniform
distribution here so i don't know that
these things are
any different than the others in terms
of importance
two of them are very related uh one is
post modeling calibration so if you're
doing a classification model
you can get class probabilities back but
those probabilities might not be
indicative of the actual event rates so
you can get like a really high
or a c curve score
but have really inaccurate um
probability estimates
um for your for your model so this would
be a way to figure that out
and potentially um recalibrate your
model to get rid of it so this is
something we would do after the model is
built so it's like we have
pre-processing the recipes we have the
model fitting via parsnip and workflows
and then this would be something that
you could you could do uh post hoc for
your model to adjust the predictions
um so that's one aspect of this another
one that i thought would rate higher
here
is probability optimization
so if you have like a two class problem
depending on how you want to balance
false negatives and false positives you
might not want to use the 0.5 cutoff
um this comes up a lot quite a bit with
um class imbalances
that if you look at the 50
cutoff for sensitivity specificity when
you have a really really large class
imbalance like sensitivity might be like
really really bad with the 0.5 cut off
and specificity might be really really
good
and depending on the application you're
doing you might want to use
methods to figure out oh well for this
like ratio of false positives or false
negatives what cutoff should i use this
is basically what an rc curve does right
so we want to have ways of optimizing
that cut off as if it were like a tuning
parameter or a model
it's not hard to do it's just that it's
like we have to add layers of post
processing to the the modeling structure
so so those two things are kind of
similar
um serialization tools
are mostly about um
like if you fit a curious model or an xg
boost model
um i think light gbm is probably like
this too
that the model object is actually saved
in memory somewhere so if you were to
like save them the parsnip object and
then quit you actually don't save your
model object because it didn't stuff it
into a
serialized
format to be saved with your r object so
we have all the tools that do this we
just have a better api
that says oh i'm i'm using the save
function on this parsnip model that uses
kiris i need to get that curious bit out
of memory and stuff it into the model
object to save it appropriately and then
when i load it have a an api that's
really easy to use that would then stuff
that
model back into appropriate place in
memory so it can be used so it's more
like a tool for like model deployment
and saving
models but then the last two items on
the list were spatial analysis models
and methods you know usually we'll put
something on the list that the people in
the group don't know a heck of a lot
about but we know that there's a lot
that could be done
and so this is something we want to get
into um you know
it ranked with the the rest of the group
so it's on our development list
um we'll get to it um but probably not
before like feature selection
and then finally like near and dear to
my heart is h2o
we've talked to aaron liddell a couple
times about this and we've looked into
some technical aspects
i don't think it would be that hard
to interface h2o to tidy models and so
the value of that was would be like you
have your data
h2o is really really really efficient
um and so what you might do is you might
use a tiny models interface for like
grid search or for parsnip but instead
of running that in your local machine
you can use
like if you chose an h2o engine you can
send that out to your h2o server and
have it do it's like really efficient
optimization models or estimation bits
and then return that object to you as if
it were done like in an r session and
use it like you would any other tiny
models object and so this is something
even though it didn't rank very high
then i think we'll we'll bump up because
number one we've wanted to do it we've
been talking about doing it forever and
we've actually done a little bit of work
on it so even though the the survey
didn't
like show that as being number one i
think we'll probably bias it a little up
in terms of its importance to us
so there's that
and then finally just want to say thanks
um thanks for the invitation to speak
also thank the team um davis vaughan
julia silke and hannah frick
amelia uh bitfelt has done a lot of work
with text recipes and themis and a bunch
of other stuff and so we've hired him
and he starts next week which is great
and then you can see the rest of people
some who aren't with us in the company
more like allison hill that a lot of
works we always want to thank her for
what she's done
but it's a tiny models team and the
teddy bears teamer
great group of people and we really
appreciate all the um the help that
everybody gives us so i always want to
emphasize that
great thank you max if we can all give
uh max a big um golf clap i'll give more
than a qualcomm real clap not just a
golf club uh thank you very much for
that wonderful talk
um
so
we have a number of questions for you
so let me let me take dusty's first go
cause that's the longest one the one i
can't copy and paste
that's okay so dusty's saying
uh boys with case weights uh after
running tune grid select the parameters
that yield the best weighted aerometric
um
yes
so if you believe that your wage for
your application should be used in
performance metrics you would just tell
like tune grid
that the weights are in this column and
everything just works for you
so we'll have an option there that's
something like
weighted performance metric equal true
or false or something like that and
that'll be the flag
that you would use to make sure that the
weights get applied
to um to like the army c values r
squared or whatnot
and then um and then you know have it be
optimized on that
uh how you do that with a custom metric
uh we're gonna enable that i know that
we'll enable that but that's davis's
thing and i'm not sure that he's done
any work on that
so
um so but yeah you know i don't know if
you can pass in a case wait i'm pretty
sure we'll allow you to do that we just
need to figure out the api or the
interface for doing that so
so yeah once we have that all working
um you should be able to do that no
problem
yeah
cool
um so a bunch of questions came in would
you like me to go through them or reopen
them
all right no you're good
cool let me go to the very top
um uh how did you make the dynamic help
page that depends on the loaded packages
oh yeah
um
well
uh i don't wanna say it's hacky but
um and it's probably gonna change a
little bit so but basically um
here i can show you just as a thumbnail
um
um
what we do is
we create a bunch of r files for every
model and engine so if i want to do
boosted trees with c50
we have an r pat or r file here that
creates a help topic for it
that it'll be called a details boost
tree c50
and that doesn't include rmd
from an rmd file that we have sitting
around in another directory
now you may look at this and be like oh
my god did you you really did that um
we're making a little better
uh in the next version of parsnip but
that rmd file has um
a bunch of code that makes like the
makes the um
the list of tuning parameters it has a
bunch of templates in it that so we
don't retype a bunch of stuff so what
what this does along with this file is
it makes like a help page an rmd i'm
sorry an rd file
in your package that has
um it even has code in it that's not
part of package dependency list in your
package because it's run through the rmd
files so when you use the document
function
in dev tools or using the api here
like
document
it builds all these these uh
engine specific pages
and so then once we have those
we know where to look for them and so
like the for example the um
let's say linear reg right the linear
reg function uses something
um you can put s expressions which is
like knitter type expressions almost
inside a man file so we have a function
that finds all those special man files
that we made
for each engine
and writes it out in rd like the rd
format that you would use an rd file
into a list so whenever you open
this help topic it re-executes this code
and writes a new list out so it's
basically we made a bunch of substrate
that we wanted to interface through the
man pages and then this magic right here
is really what makes it dynamic
um is we wrote a little internal
parser function that makes a list of
engines for this particular model
and that
that's what makes the list
and then it re-renders each time you
load a package like this i feel like
this makes brian ripley cry
well they they probably love it because
they don't have to touch this at all
so so the you know that's the reason we
use include r b in a lot of places
um in like these particular
files here is these are not in these are
not even these rmd files aren't even in
the um the submission of crayon they get
rendered locally and we'll probably make
a github actions and do this they get
rendered at some point outside of the
our command build structure
and then they're just like markdown
files
so the code is in like paragraphs
basically to cram it's not like in
examples it's not in
like functions
so we can put like tiny bottles or
whatever like packs we want to use in
these rmd files
because they're treated as text and not
as actual code for cram
i still can't get over how like it just
repopulates the help file right when you
load something that's really cool that's
awesome that magic yeah yeah we did the
first time we did this was for the
generics package so this is something
that um i had wrote a really probably
bad implementation did something vaguely
close to this and then i think how they
wrote that
that whole sd thing that we use
i think
i mean if if you want to like send me an
email like in a month because i'm
probably going to rewrite the code that
does all this in parsnip but it'll be
the same sort of strategy the the
specifics might change a little bit but
that that's a general strategy
cool thank you
um
and to jump around the order the
questions were asked and i'll try to you
know um you know punch them together the
ones that seem to go together well
uh you talk about poisson regression
uh what mode like if is it linear reg
and just setting a mode for position
regression or like what's the modeling
function going to be
yeah that was that's interesting because
like here we'll go back to the other
session
so like when you load
um boss on
reg
oh i think it's because i installed
something differently um
sorry the development version's open
uh we treat that as a like a regression
problem so they're integers right um but
they're numbers so we decided to treat
poisson regression as like a regression
mode as opposed to like a
like a poisson mode
um
so
so for example like when you use poisson
regression i think the default uh engine
is um
is uh glm and so for example we set the
family equal to poisson for you
and that kind of thing
um so the poisson reg package has like
uh i think it has a glimnet stan
engines and then i think um it has some
zero-inflated
uh poisson models in it too so we just
treat that as like
what's that can we do quasi-poisson
uh i think so yeah i think you can um
i think you can override the family
option so if you want to do like
if you want to do like um over
dispersion plus on over dispersed models
you can say family equal to quasi link
equal log or whatever it is
um and do that
i know i've done that so i think that's
how you do it is you just re-specify
family if you wanted to be something
different and that would be that would
be in the set engine function you do
that for the engine specific option
right okay
and oh and for glenda you can pass that
as a string
yes i believe so all right cool
um someone's asking these theme teams to
go together um
when will the multilevel mod package be
on crayon
uh soon so um
i'm writing like a a general like get
started vignette for it now
um once that once that's done it's
basically like not done in development
but i think it's like regular crayon
the problem is it depends on the
developed parsnip so we have to submit
parchment before that and that has a
bunch of changes that we still need to
work out so
i'm hoping like i'm hoping um
january i think january is fairly
realistic okay for that to be on crayon
um
[Music]
it's i have like a i have like a an ios
list of like things that are 90 done and
this is what this has been there like
it's close i just haven't had time to
push her over the edge and so i've spent
a lot of time on it recently so
should be pretty soon
so you'll be getting a talk soon at the
meet up to show us the interface forks i
know there's like this can be a more
difficult interface to uh set up
garrett you might remember i talked
about this at the uh our conference one
year yes i want to have a follow-up
okay
and that's basically that's what the
vignette that i've been writing is like
okay
so i have these engines like how do i do
my random effects specification with
with tiny models so that's the part that
i've been doc spending the most
documentation on and that'll also be
like the
like the engine specific stuff so if i
did like
see if i
worked this uh
install but like um i made like ge is
maybe a good example
like there's some particulars about how
you fit that model here
so you know we give you a lot of like oh
if you want to use it with a workflow
how would you do that
so um or how would you specify the the
correlation structure
so for each one of these multi-level mod
interfaces they're they're very much
like gams their format interface is very
non-standard compared to your basic r
functions
so both in vignettes and with the engine
specific documentation we'll have a lot
of examples about
like like like here's a good example
like the gls function god this is
something that drives me nuts
you can fit the exact same model using
like lme and gls like the the inner the
coefficients are all the same the
the random effects are fitted the same
but the same package uses different
degrees of freedom calculations
depending on what model you're fitting
which i spent maybe like a day and a
half trying to figure out like two
decades ago so like we try to document
these things
um as they come up and in the specifics
of the syntax as well as sort of any
gotchas we try to put in the engine
documentation because
like once once you have to figure this
out you never forget it and you don't
want everybody else anybody else to
think about this problem again so
there'll be quite a lot here in terms of
like how these models are specified and
then some things like this you should
know about so we'll document
like i don't believe it's possible to
over document something
but the engine specific documentation
allows us to stash it somewhere where it
doesn't get in your way you never have
to look at it until you want to actually
do that in which case we've written down
everything we can think of about that
particular
model in engine
and then sticking multi-level models um
i know stan you could specify a prior
like a horseshoe prior to get like a
lasso-like effect uh will we be able to
set the priors
yeah you can do that you can do that
with porcelain today so you um
pass that in as the engine argument
so again like um i think we even listed
here for
stan
so like we list like you know i think
most of the time uh for
unless you have a if you're just doing
like um
like random intercept models you can set
the intercept prior which does
most of the work you want to
but there's other prior functions and
these would be passed in as engine
specific options so we we kind of list
them out here
now there's a question from me is
convention specific
at what point is something
engine specific at what point is it a
model specific that's only used by one
engine like xg boost there's a bunch of
boost tree there's a bunch of arguments
that are only used for xg boost but
there's other xgb boost stuff that you
pass in through set engines like where
is that cut off
uh it's it's honestly it's subjective
it's like .05
like you have to do something and it's
not going to be great but you have to
pick it somewhere
um and sometimes it's really easy
like with a
radial basis function support vector
machine it doesn't matter what engine it
is they're going to be the same options
but with especially with boosting
like c5 has different options in light
gbm which has different options than xg
boost and so on so we just try to find
like the the
the best intersection of those and then
those are the main options and the
others are engine arguments
and since i diverted us onto xg boost um
i saw recently added support for
regression with xg boost so is that a
linear reg or is that a boost ray like
what's the what's the model type
did we
you offer um l1 and l2 penalization on
it which i think is only available for
like the
the linear models not the tree models
like is the gb linear methods
i remember doing that maybe somebody
else contributed that i didn't do it
what do you
all right so i did see a blog post i
think from julia that you've added the
parameters for the l1 parameter and the
l2 parameter um in there and that's if
you look in the actual
documentation that's for gb linear not
gb boost
yeah not gb treatment i feel funny that
i don't know the answer to that question
but we have a lot of people that
contribute so
yeah maybe
no i don't know i have to look if you
figure it out let me know and i'd like
to
know what's in there so yeah fair enough
thanks i'm i think it's exciting to use
xg boost as a linear regression engine
that's kind of fun
yeah we've added like in censored we
have like m boost which lets you do like
linear boosting
um
especially for like cox models and
things like that can be very nice
since you're speaking of um survival
models um
will you be offering you sort of
mentioned it but we'll be offering
anderson gill for multiple events
uh that's the plan
so what what we're spending a lot of
time now figuring out is there's a bunch
of stuff that the survival package does
we need to figure out if we need to have
our own api
or like let's say like time dependent
covariance there's at least two ways of
doing that
the survival package lets you do it in
the formula but then if there are other
engines that let you do time dependent
covariates
that won't play well with other engines
because the way that the survival
package is done
is used um
it's really like
uh i don't know how to say it it's
really like hey i
this will work for my package but i'm
not going to really make it available to
anything else
and we've had some conversations where
that's not going to change um
so what we're trying to do with things
like that like anderson gills to figure
out like all right
so if that works fine in survival where
else might that be applicable
like and can we use that in other places
and if we think we can and we can't get
it out of survival then we have to think
of like oh wait how would we
like the stratification is a really good
example of that making that work with
glimnet was a little bit of a chore
but we wanted to be like the same
interface and everything so
so that's what we do right now we're
looking at like interval censoring like
like competing risks and all like the
the little like second secondary like
survival analyses that people do
and figure out if um
if
those will work for us
uh everywhere
or um
or if we need to reimplement so that's
kind of what we're spending our time on
so i think that those things will happen
um
sequentially
so you know you might you might have
like
mostly support for time-dependent
covariates initially until we can get it
implemented everywhere
um and we already have some examples of
that in the package where we had to go
back and make things
like
here's a good example is
in the survival package
from what i can tell there's only two
ways to specify what you want your
baseline hazard group to be
and i can give you a really common
design in pharma that doesn't work for
either of those two methods
and so one thing that we want to do is
make a general interface for all these
models to say oh here's the covariate
pattern in my predictors that defines
the baseline hazard
so if you really want to fix that to a
very very specific set of covariates
uh we want to give you an interface to
do that which means we're gonna have to
rewrite a bunch of survival stuff that's
there
so just making all this stuff work
together it's it's really it's
unfortunate because we'd love to have a
really reusable interface that people
can use
but none of these packages for survival
analysis are written that way they're
all their own little fighters and then
you know they don't intersect at all and
to try to get them to intersect is
almost impossible so you have to make
like a third thing that
has that venn diagram overlapped with
them
so it's it's a little bit unfortunate
but that's just how it's been done
15 set of standards
yeah but i mean the good news is users
don't ever have to worry about that
right like we'll just make that happen
under the hood and like i mean that's
been like my career in our it's just
like i'll make it work
before we get to more uh censoring
questions joey said in the chat that
lambda and alpha are available as
parameters for tree booster not just gb
linear
that's news to me i've every time i read
the documentation i always thought they
were just gb linear i'm very happy to be
wrong about this so joey thank you i'm
going to reread the documentation again
they've updated their api quite a bit um
like their mtri parameter
was like per tree originally and then we
realized and so we mapped it to that
parameter
in parse net but then they made it per
split which is how every other like
random forest method works so we had to
go back and update that so it was the
more appropriate parameter so like it
sometimes it's frustrating because they
change things but it's almost always a
change for the better so that's it's a
good change if that's what they can do
yeah and they've also recently made a
change about their their default eval
metric so every time i use it with you
guys it uh it gives me a warning message
that fits out
yeah so we know
yes i put it on github and and it hasn't
been resolved yet um and joey goes
through vr while you're out there buddy
i i surface issues i'm not as good at
programming as you are so i let the
expert do it
um and joey posted the link to the
github page so thank you joey i'm going
to dive into that as soon as this talks
over that's awesome
um back to censoring um when you do the
censoring you did it without a recipe
does the does using the formula for fit
play nicely of recipes
yes
so you can you can use a recipe
independent of the formula used for
fitting
um so like for example we had somebody
who wanted to use splines through a
recipe
and so that you can make the splines
using
a recipe and then have the formula
method use those columns
um it's and we have documentation on
this
um much it's very much like the
multi-level modeling stuff is like those
the survival formulas
um
specify a lot in them
so we've written everything so that you
can do a bunch of other complicated
stuff like recipes or whatnot or even if
it's not complicated
but still
use that formula method that you have
um
nicely so so it all plays together
um we might add like a step function to
make that serve object
um we just need to make sure that that
doesn't fail when you have new data
without the outcome
um but i think i i first i thought oh we
shouldn't do that but then i think we
will have it because the weird thing
about that serve object is
it's actually a it's like a
it's like a
like three raccoons in a trench coat
it's you take two vectors together and
it makes a vector but it's actually a
matrix
so depending on how you attach it to the
data frame
you could actually bork your data frame
by doing that
um
so there's like certain ways to add the
serve object to a data frame
that make it look nice and others that
don't
so like if we do like step serve or
something like that we'll let you make
that object and we'll attach it as a
column in the the best way
so it doesn't look like somebody vomited
on the
screen when you show it
yeah
is jared frozen
all right
i will keep going
jared's at least on my screen is frozen
um
nom are you familiar with piecewise
exponential additive models no i do not
um there goes jared
um
so let's rearrange plus on models okay
i will look into that um they're good
for spatial survival analysis excellent
um
i will look into that i'm we're we're
probably going to start working on a
second edition of
apply predictive modeling and i want to
add a lot more about like additive
um
dams and things like that which we
didn't have space for in the first
edition so this is excellent
hi max i'm back if you can hear me
yeah we're good
all right cool i thought you first my
whole computer is bored i'm afraid to
turn it off in case i can't close the
whole zoom meeting so yeah don't do that
yeah i'll do my best to ask questions i
have listed on my phone right now um if
you want i don't think there's a lot
left
there's a few other ones um i got so
yeah you go through what you found and i
have a few more
are you
can you hear me
all right cool cool um
let's turn our attention to gams then uh
i know you just had a question about
gams
um
yeah
similar to the uh multi-level model
question when will the game package be
on cran
like the ability to use games in person
you can do that uh
we we added that the last version so gen
model right
and then similarly i know we have no one
here
you have all sorts of gam packages you
have you know a bunch of different
packages what packages do you offer uh
for games
right now just mgcv um but happy to add
more of them honestly i love this
particular model
um
it's up there with mars and gams are
like
my two like favorite sort of quasi
machine learning
but not really models um they're very
similar in some ways so yeah bring bring
the cams on
yeah because i know there's like there's
dams there's like these beijing gams
which i think you could fix
and i know there's like the big ga mmm
for a big game no that's multi-level
games there's also spam for big games
there's all sorts of them
yeah
yeah i don't want to go down too far
down the rabbit hole but yeah but i'd
love to do more of them
i'd love to be able to use more of them
so
add them in as fast as you can
um
so i think that's everything for gams
then there's a question um do you ever
work with the original package authors
when trying to uh rework some of this
stuff
we try to um
like for survival models there's a great
package called flex serve
and like they're originally their
prediction stuff was done from the
summary function which is kind of weird
so like we talked to them about that and
um so yeah we we do reach out to people
a fair amount like um
if there's things that seem like oh like
you know
you have to like
get a sense of like um
you know
try to predict how
much traction you'll get like like if
somebody has like a
you know a nice package but it doesn't
let's like i don't understand how this
happens but people make like modeling
packages that don't have predict
functions
right and you're like okay
so maybe add a predict function but if
it's a package that hasn't been updated
in like three years and it's like huh
um we'll often just send them an email
to see if they respond
um and i'd say like
usually
we'll try to collaborate with people
that we've talked to or seen
presentations of theirs so we know that
they're so active and are things like
that so
it all depends on not like who they are
like oh i need to know them or something
like that it's just that we have like a
rough outline as to like who's going to
respond and who's not so
um we try to as much as we can
um and more about development so uh
there's one node if they adapt tidy
models will be any reason to also use
carrot
sure yeah i mean
you know i think there's this venn
diagram
where there's carrot stuff that tiny
models can't or won't do and vice versa
i think the choice between some of that
stuff is it's almost like the choice
between
well i feel like the main delimiter the
limiter between like python and r stuff
is like which language feels more
natural to you
and i think the same is true like if
you're
if you're a more pythonic person then
mlr3 might seem like great to you but if
you're not like a big fan of the
tinyverse
then you might not like like piping all
the stuff in for tiny models so maybe
carrots like what you'd be down with
so i think there will be differences in
functionality
um but i think the main delimiter
between all these things is basically
the programming style at this point
i don't know people could disagree with
that but maybe it's because i see under
the hoods of of all of them and i don't
think they're all that
really fundamentally different like like
for example i don't think there's ever
going to be a real speed difference
between them because they're all relying
on the same underlying
model functions
so it's not like the random forest
function works faster in
carat than it does in tidy models
um so i don't know that there's much of
a performance difference
it's just like
how you like to program i think is
really the thing
that
will make you go to one or the other
and you know speaking of python uh you
mentioned you know you know we know we
have scikit-learn which is you know
similar to carrot now there's pie carrot
which talk about flattery is a great
imitation is a great form of flattery um
yeah
what is pie carrot getting people i'm
not sure you should know this what was
pie carrot getting people that
scikit-learn isn't already
uh i don't know like uh
i think when they started that
package they sent me a note and said hey
is this cool and i was like yeah sure
it's fine with me i did in my head think
like well what does that do do the
second learn doesn't but it might be
that the interface is different i don't
know i don't know enough about it to be
honest with you maybe it's more
what's that
maybe it's more r
like maybe yeah i don't know
um i've i've got enough things to read
about in research i don't want to go
into python to figure that stuff out
fair enough
um
we have we have actually a bunch of
different topics coming up um one is
like in uh fable you can take a
transformation of the outcome variable
and then when you make a prediction it
automatically undoes the transformation
yeah
how can we do that here all of in
standard and tidy models where we have
our data we take a log of an outcome
variable then we make predictions it's
on the exponentiated scale
yeah so that's what like the
post-processing stuff i mentioned the
survey like calibration
and
threshold optimization once we get that
in place then we can enable that because
what we want to do is we don't want to
make that prediction transformation
until after you've computed performance
i mean almost like i mean 90 of the time
the reason
you would let's say log numeric variable
is because
you stabilize the variance and it makes
sense to calculate the metrics on that
stabilized scale
but that doesn't mean when you get the
data out you don't want it like when you
get it back in a data frame of
predictions you might want it in the
original units
so the post-processing stuff once we get
that set up then that's where it'll
happen
so like in your workflow you can do like
you know workflow
uh
[Music]
with workflows you can do like a
workflow you know add recipe
add model
and then you might the post processing
will allow you to do like um
add
transformation
transformation or something like that
for the outcome and then you can be like
i don't know like dot y is equal to log
dot y or so i don't know what the
interface is going to be
but but that's something that we will
enable you to do
but but again this will happen
we have to be careful to make sure this
happens after
performance calculation because that's
pretty important but also you got to
take a log before you fit the model and
you can't put that in recipes so where
does that go then
yeah well if it's a deterministic
transformation like the log we advise
people to do it outside of the recipe
yeah yeah i know
it's disappointing but i mean look
here's the thing is in tiny models we go
to great pains to firewall things and
david robinson wrote a great blog post
about like guard rails and stuff and
tidy models
and we can't
we can't like have
can't let you mess with the outcome data
and include that outcome data when
you're not supposed to have the outcome
data like if you're making predictions
of new samples you're not supposed to
have the outcome data and if we make
that available then it opens the
potential for like
um
accidental or not like like information
leakage and things like that
you're doing that predicting ignore the
outcomes like allow you to do it for the
training data but it ignores it when you
get new data
yeah but we we that's the problem is
even when you're computing performance
within like cross-validation we consider
new data new data
because otherwise it might be
easier hard to
use that data to then inform the
prediction you know that we literally
like firewall that stuff off so you
can't either by accident or not do that
so um that's that's the trouble with it
is in putting those guardrails in i
think i think the the pain that you
suffer by having to do the
transformation ahead of time
is for me
a good trade-off
um
against the risk of accidentally
contaminating your
performance metrics by overfitting
accidentally
um
that to me that's like the worst thing
you could do because then it looks like
like for example like both from a
substantive like you don't want that to
happen but from a perception standpoint
we don't want somebody to do that with
3d models to be like tiny models messed
up my thing like it said i had 95
accuracy but now it's like 80 because it
overfit and that would be on us so like
we want to put those guardrails in
all right the next time i see you would
get whiskey i'm going to argue more to
you about this yeah everybody does
everybody everybody targets you all the
time
all right well i will continue arguing
with you about that the next time i ever
get to see you
um but turning our attention a little
bit right now um you talked about the um
the deploying and the api
um
how would you pass a you have your model
you have to pass a row of data for like
tabular data how do you pass that into
the api call
can you pass a row of json does he have
to pass like a separate parameter for
each column
no like uh when you're like once you
have them all deployed that you just
give it a row of json or as many rows as
you want of json
like if you if you were to take your
like
like data frame and use like is it two
json i can't remember the name of the
function
but it would basically write out that
same tabular structure
and then that's what you would give to
the api called it would give you back
um basically like a vector predictions
in json format
all right like an array yeah
nice
yeah um and it looked like predict was a
put call not a get call um can you
explain the difference between those two
i can't
they're in my area
i would ask where's julia or like
somebody like um kelly o'brien about
that
so it is
it is a you know get in post um
the nuances of that is nothing i've ever
had to deal with so i'm not like the
person you want to ask about that all
right julia if you're here kelly over
here tell us in the chat
um
i believe you already answered the
question about pam's
yeah that seems pretty cool
um then we have a question of how do you
imagine implementing the feature
selection methods and tidy models should
feature selection be in recipes or what
about large global methods such as
genetic algorithms or simulated
annealing
yeah that's a great question um
we the i think the plan is to do it both
ways
so for example um
i could show you code but i don't want
to like
be like oh that's how it's going to work
i mean what we can do is we can put some
like
supervised um recipe steps in there to
say like hey
at any step in the recipe you can say
like filter on all the numeric
predictors
that have an rc score
against the outcome that's greater than
0.8 or you could say give me the top
three
rc scored
predictors so what we'll have is like
two or three
recipe functions
that will let you filter in different
ways that you want to just like any
other recipe step
that's really simple to use and that
fits into everything else we have right
so that's nice
the downside to doing that is in some
cases it could be computationally
inefficient so imagine you have a recipe
step that will compute like the random
forest
uh feature
um
very important scores and then you say
oh give me the top three or the top
seven and you can make that a tuning
parameter you could say like tune on the
number of things to save
as measured by the random forced
importance
so when you resample that
and let's say you're tuning model
parameters when you resample that we try
to make it as efficient as possible but
you would end up
doing that redundant calculation more
times than you have to
so
the recipe steps will make it really
easy to do that but they might not be
very computationally efficient
and if you if you use like the number of
terms to retain from the variable
important scores that's basically
recursive feature elimination so the
other thing that we'll do in addition to
those recipe steps is we'll just give
you a proper
like recursive feature elimination
function that will look i think it's
going to be called like tune predictors
or something like that
that will
you give it your recipe and your model
and then it basically
takes the original columns the
predictors and basically does recursive
feature elimination on those
so what we'll do is we'll have like
high level interfaces like that one the
cursor feature elimination
uh interface or lower level things that
you can just insert into recipes where
you want
um the difference is
one will be more fully featured like in
recipes the other will have fewer
features but will be more efficient
so we'll have um several ways of doing
it i think
yeah
yeah i've thought about this like a lot
a lot
um
and and because we once we started using
recipes and carrot that's where all this
stuff came up like well wait what's are
we doing recursive feature elimination
are we doing recursive like predictor
elimination
um so it gets fairly complicated pretty
quickly yeah
i was teaching a class to another
professor and they wanted to show
stepwise variable selection like let's
use glumna they said we need to show
stepwise like i can't deal with tiny
models what am i supposed to do so i
think they should consider that a sign
that they're using the wrong tool
i'm trying slowly i am
or you can make a custom model or a
model engine for that and put in a
package and
you know i'm not going to say no to that
but like at the same time i don't think
that i want to
i don't think i want to support that
yeah i understand that here's the thing
is you get your model out of that all
the standard errors are wrong
they're not right they're just wrong and
so for me it's really hard to enable
something that
the fundamental statistics that
everybody's going to look at are
completely wrong so
on the flip side if you do glimnet
you're not getting any standard errors
that's why you would use stand in
horseshoe prior
even better and and half as fast
um some more questions just came in i
know we're getting kind of late here but
some good questions here
um there's a question about statistical
forecasting you know forecasting right
now uh it seems to be that tidy verts
and rob hyman's packages are doing a lot
of it i know there is model time from
matt bancho are there any plans to start
doing more um forecasting methods and
tidy models or are you just going to
leave that over to rob's team and matt's
teams
the latter
rob siemens mass teams is that i think
both rob's system and matt's system are
really good
they're approaching it from different
perspectives and matt's doing a lot of
like like we have the most contact with
matt the the
rob stuff is really great but it's not
it's not really like tidy models right
so it's really hard for us
to um
to mix and match some of those things
because they're fundament fundamentally
different systems
um the stuff that matt is doing is built
on top of tidy models and so when matt
if and when matt says oh be great if i
could do this we will definitely help
facilitate all that he's also wrapping
some of like
rob stuff into like um recipes and
things like that so
a lot of rob's older stuff it seems like
forecast more than fable
yeah
so here's the thing is we have two sets
of people
that are doing similar things that are
different enough where they're hard to
merge
but two really smart people who know a
lot about the that subject
we wouldn't like
spend another like group of people doing
more of the same stuff
because you know whether it's spatial
analysis or fairness metrics we would
rather
like go in a direction that nobody's
being served by
so
it would be great if we had all that
stuff under one sort of api
but both of those apis are pretty good
and i don't think the tiny models team
should spend a lot of time on that
because
you know there are other areas that just
we don't have anything for so that's
sort of how we try to prioritize
um
i know we are getting late but i really
want to get some of these um there's a
question about are multi-level model
recipes coming like centering group wise
centering and scaling
we we
yeah there's there's been a lot of like
github issues about this
is the one i i talked to and closed the
other day was i think some people want
like an omnibus sort of like overall
group by like like a step group by so
that any calculations done after that
before step one group we're all group
wise um i don't want to do that i would
rather approach it from a case-by-case
basis which may seem
inefficient
but you could do horrible damage to your
data analysis by enabling like a general
purpose thing
like before i left my last job i had a
really big argument with technical
argument with somebody because they were
doing
they were doing some text analysis and
they were creating features in the data
based on what the outcome class was
so they're using the outcome to create
the features
and i'm like what do you do when you
don't have the outcome like we just put
both in the model whichever one works
well is the better one
and i'm like oh my god that's like no no
don't do that so like the thing i want
to protect against is people
like accidentally encoding the outcome
data into their features
right and so that's where the the
grouping stuff
so you know they're they're i'm
convinced like uh this person named
clayton who contributes a lot to issues
and to code for us
he must work with panel data i think he
mentioned a lot and i i've read about
him a bunch of that but i don't know
well enough to know
how that should work but i can envision
situations where
like group by sort of operations would
be really good for specific types of
operations look i would love to make a
package that does like chem informatics
signal processing like spectra
processing because i love doing that
type of stuff even though i don't do it
anymore but that would have to have some
like group by sort of functionality
embedded into the recipe
but i would write recipe steps for that
purpose that would do that as opposed to
enabling like an overall general purpose
like group by sort of structure
so
um so i'm okay with doing it but i would
like it to be not isolated but i want to
have like really good
specific use cases as opposed to just
enable everything to be grouped by
so yeah it's not it's not what you want
to hear if you want those things but i
think the option is to just let's put in
some issues and go through it and figure
out what what's a good idea what's not
all right yeah so i think as andrew
mentioned it go on github and suggest it
and help
craft what you're doing
um
the word wrong for a package name for
the fork for your uh
for the stepwise variable selection he
says he did a check it's available on
crayon the name wrong is available on
crayon
you just need to get it past crayon see
if they'll take the word wrong
oh i don't think they'll care
if we can get lubricated through wrong
should be fine i've heard stories that
they care about like acronyms certain
acronyms and function names so they do
they do like i think the original pack
the original name was pkg they were like
i think they were like no you can't do
that yeah the package package
yeah
yeah
that's the way they are all right just a
handful more um have you ever thought
about taking some models and
re-implementing them using c plus plus
thought about it we do that periodically
not with models we do that with
performance metrics sometimes
um
what i've been doing
uh with a package i'm probably going to
change the name of this package it's
called lantern right now
which is like torch-based
implementations of certain models like
tabular models
um i didn't i mean daniel who works with
us told me later on that lantern is
actually like a a python thing built on
top of torch i think it's for like
insulation so i think i'm going to call
it bray for like creme brulee because
i'm all about the food but um
so like we've done a little bit of that
with like
torch and curious a little bit
um
i wouldn't mind re-implementing things
in c plus
um
there i won't out the person but about
four years ago
i talked to a graduate student who
rewrote all of the regularized glen
knight type models because there's all
these like limnet like packages with
different penalties and they wrote all
that from scratch and c plus plus into
an r package and every year i emailed
that person saying
is it done yet can you put it on crayon
like i i would love in it i would love
to have
like bottom-up reimplementations of a
lot of things uh if i had a lot more
resources i actually would really really
do that um and eventually i think we
will get to that like when
we're not gonna get like the feature
complete anytime soon
but at some point like we'll have a
little bit more
uh resource bandwidth and those are the
types of things that would be like all
right what's on my list with wishlist i
would like to have a better
implementation of this or that and i
think we would definitely go down the
road and if there's something that is
like killing us in the meantime we'd
probably get like a summer intern or
something to start working on it so yeah
i'd love to do that we just we don't
prioritize that really high because if
it exists
you know we want to do things that don't
exist
all right cool i mean i think we covered
just about everything
so um unless you see anything that's
sneaking by you there was a question
actually earlier there's another
question about cameo meant this and that
it was like corex it was um
correlation explanation i believe uh so
yeah um
with the python r
yeah um put a put a um
github issue in the recipes and give us
some like references what's worth
looking at
i know for my sake i want to see a
ranking engine and i want to see cap
boost and light gbm
implemented also
so after i get through like
a multi-level mod and maybe
lantern
i want to loop back with the treesnet
people and get
get that on crayon
very cool um
is cat boost even working for art right
now
it is um
i use it uh as part of a talker you had
to cut out for time but it was working
with the gpu and everything
have you installed it lately
yeah i would say in september
the thing is like i installed it using
the binaries
yeah yeah that's the problem is like i
don't i don't want to say like a bottle
has to be um crane for us to to have an
engine for it but like
it's i can't get it installed on my mac
over and over again i can't get it
compiled so
like if i can't do development on it
then i certainly don't have time or unit
tests and things like that
but as far as um
light gbm we had james lamb uh give a
talk of the meet up earlier this year
watching it was very good
right yeah he's great and so i think i
don't know if that's on korean yet but
they definitely did they're cool there
is and they made even they built they
haven't done it yet but i think that i
suggested they make um
uci cd to make the pre-built gpu
binaries also
right without never being at this rate
it was on crayon and then like like two
days later got taken off
because of somebody on crayon got
persnickety about something and then got
back on
so
but yeah that's and i've used that that
seems to work great so
and we in the treesnet package
uh has a personal vengeance for that so
they haven't done much development on
that so one thing i'll do
maybe in february is go back to that
package just update it in terms of all
the changes to parsnip and then make
that work and then we can send it to
cram because it's also got the party
i added the the party package and like
mboos type stuff it's got the tree
package
and
maybe one other
in there so it's got some really cool
stuff in it we just need to get it on
crayon
nice
very cool um so i think you know we've
gone two hours i had a blast listening
to this i hope everyone else enjoyed
this as much as i did at least
um i want to thank max for being our
december 2021 speaker um hopefully he'll
lead us out of this pandemic with this
great talk
i'm not sure what type of magical powers
he has but hopefully so thank you max
for being here i will give you another
round of golf clapping all right great
and everyone hope to see you at the
conference next week at the next five
months of meetups that we have planned
and we'll have a whole bunch of good fun
ones and we'll definitely get max
scheduled for some time next year again
and give us another update on some of
this stuff
okay thank you
thanks bye